we are joined now by the design guru of
the drew crew and this show the one the
only mikael welch
so excited to be here i mean we are
kicking off our happy place macau design
week yes we all love design week right
please do you mind if i just brag
quickly about your clients really
quickly gosh tell me let's see uh
michelle obama
right
yeah i got an opportunity to do a
project with her uh-huh and um who else
mikael
no you said you were good i'm going to
sound like i'm bragging about i said but
you know oprah
faith hill you know just a few oh my
gosh and michael
your talent
is just unparalleled your aesthetic your
taste your knowledge is so impeccable so
i'm really excited to do some headlines
with you and get your opinion your
expert eye and ears nose and mouth on a
few subjects let's do it all right
why don't you take the story mikael all
right so here's a fun one guys so in
home design everyone's familiar with the
term open concept right that's that one
wide open interior space that has lots
of room move and flow
well guess what martha stewart the queen
she has said that there are reports
coming back the walls are now coming
back into style
and she's saying that people are opting
for the section off rooms now so this is
kind of evolved from you know all of us
and our lives in the pandemic right
we're at home a lot more people are just
like craving that separate defined space
you know whether it's a different mode
for working relaxing zooming etc but hey
that's what martha said so let's see
what we think
i think it's interesting because i've
been reading so many design trends like
they're kind of coming out of the
woodworks it's amazing so i keep reading
that separate rooms are now much more on
trend because people are working from
home
um and they need the separation from
their partners or family or a designated
area that sort of has that energy and
function and then when you switch rooms
it's like you're in a different
reality and space i mean i really think
it's this like you sit at home with your
partner and now your kids have become
like your co-workers it's a lot like the
kids are running around the dog like
it's a lot so it's like can we corral
this and like get everyone into a
separate room so that we can all think
like we need that no i like to do no no
i like an open concept okay because i
like to do a lot at once i'm doing
laundry i'm cooking i'm watching 90 day
fiance and i'm doing it all
in a big one big space
and i know that maybe that's like
aesthetically not the most beautiful but
like functionality-wise i get it done
you want to see it all right yes please
i need like get away from me for a
second like i don't want to hear your
zoom call like i don't listen uh listen
let me have my own space where i can
just go and i can think oh you could
have your space i'll be in the rest of
the house enjoy your little room
all right well how about this another
big design trend blowing up pinterest
right now is called
dopamine decor in metro reports it's all
about creating that interior space that
boosts your mood people are leaning into
a ton of bold colors too like you're
saying fun shapes poppy wallpapers now
are you seeing this kind of trend in
design right now not on my instagram
feed
i will say this i think it works for
the right person i think if you do it in
doses
it's something you can live with but
that's a lot like that looks like a
crayon blocks exploded like i don't know
if i can live like that every day listen
i've said before on the show that i my
house is just white you know like i i do
need a little bit of this because there
isn't you love a vanilla
but then when you go into a space well
maybe you guys have done this when you
walk to a restaurant or a bathroom or
something that's like there's a bold
wallpaper i think oh my god i would love
to do this i just don't know how to do
this i have an idea what is that
well first of all you could like start
with a bathroom okay like a little
powder powder yeah what if we did
something at ross's house
oh and not tell them what it is no no
we'll just have anxiety about it oh yeah
i'll have total anxiety but i'm in i'm
in i mean i'm nervous but i'm in
um
i like that okay all right we want to
take on a design challenge rush this is
all happening in real time right now i
don't want to like take on a room in
your house you could pick what it is you
could pick us a bathroom okay or like a
sitting room or whatever i love it
i don't know what it is
what do you think i live in like downton
abbey
okay um will you give michelle and i the
keys to your house
you are hired yes you are
[Applause]
before we go to commercial break what is
one thing that you're really loving
right now as a top designer that you
could share with us okay i'm afraid you
know this aggressive audience i don't
know but um
loving this new black trend with like
matte black and people are painting like
their kitchen counters they're chaining
like you know their kitchen islands
people are not afraid to use black now
as like an accent color
and so that's a big trend that i'm
loving
embracing it and i also think another
thing is just like embracing the 90s but
the good 90s like the proper forest
green and like you're going to see now
like lots of archways
and it's like the good part of the 90s
that we're bringing back
[Music]